Today.
We welcome Dr. John Medina who has actually we're bucketing and back.
He has been here in 2008 and 2010.
Um,
welcome back John.
And uh,
he's a professor of bioengineering at the University of Washington School of
medicine.
Uh,
his books includes brain roles,
brain rules for the baby brain rules for aging well,
which is the one that he's going to talk to you today,
which I think could apply to everybody in this room.
And um,
so yeah,
so let me welcome Dr. Medina.
Well,
it's great to be back.
I've done the last two over in the California office as the San Francisco,
so I appreciate the invitation to come back here and thank you for taking part
of your afternoon to spend with a developmental molecular biologist.
We are not known for giving compelling speeches and you've just had lunch.
So I will put the professor perfectly understands if you need to kind of roll
over and take a nap while it as I'm talking.
But if you're not,
we're going to be talking about this guy.
So third one in the series a,
a brain rules for baby brain rules.
We kind of in the middle and then brain rules for aging.
Well,
so birth,
life and death all at once at the same time and do so in about 50 minutes
specifically.
I'm going to be dividing this talking to three parts.
I'm going to introduce buy in.
So doing introduce the newest member of the trio.
Uh,
the title of the talk is the importance of friends learning.
And this is weird nostalgia and we're going to talk about some from brain
science to behavior.
My research interests are the genetics of psychiatric disorders.
I spent a long time thinking about how the brain develops in the womb at the
level of cell and gene.
And then what happens when things screw up in years later,
you get a psychiatric disorder.
So I have to speak three dialects of brain science,
the,
uh,
have to be at home in the behavioral world and in the cellular world and my home
base,
which is on the Helix,
uh,
the world of biochemistry and uh,
um,
and uh,
neurobiology.
So on the basis of some of that experience.
I'm going to divide this introduction to the book brain rules for aging.
Well do three parts,
part one.
I'll talk to you a little bit about the origin of the book and then I can't do
the whole thing.
So when I thought I would do is that I would talk about the first chapter,
which is the important of friendships,
part three of the last chapter of the power of reminiscing.
And if there's any time left at all,
I'll give a few comments about the middle of the chapter.
We'll have a hard stop certainly at two o'clock and I'll try and finish a little
before then so that there's some time for Q and a and the microphones.
Okay.
So this book is all about human behavior as most of my books are,
which means it's a discussion about nature and nurture and for all ages as I
hope to show.
But I'd like to give you an example of how nature and nurture work together in
this subject.
And then so illustrate the beginnings of the book.
What I have here is a list of lyrics in their day.
They were the number one song of their time.
I'm going to keep telling you the lyrics and I'm not going to sing them.
You see why I went in the molecular sciences?
If I am,
I tried to say,
well,
he didn't marry a musician.
If you recognize the melody though,
I want you to slip up your hand.
If you don't mind everybody else,
I would like you to look at the person who just slipped up their hand and assess
their relative.
Okay?
Ready?
Here's the first one.
If there's a bustle in your hedge row,
don't be alarmed.
Now it's just a spring clean for the May Queen.
Yes,
there are two paths you can go buy,
but in the long run,
what is that song?
Stairway to heaven,
1971 album for him.
1975 as a single released.
Okay.
Number two,
a traffic jam.
When you're already late.
I no smoking sign on your cigarette break.
It's like 10,000 spoons with all you need is a knife.
It's like meeting the man of your dreams and then meeting his beautiful wife
Alanis Morissette off the album,
jagged little pill,
1991 very good.
Lyric number three we break up.
You call me,
I love you.
Ooh,
we called it off again last night,
but Ooh,
this time I'm telling you,
I'm telling you we are never ever,
ever getting back together.
Yes,
and Dee Taylor Swift,
2012 for that three quarters of you that did not raise your hand.
This is an example of nature and nurture and here's how that works and what
we're going to be talking about today,
which is the gyro sciences nature.
You may have heard some of these songs in your tween.
Certainly they were a well established and they sold lots of a copy in their
time.
What year you were a teen dependent upon when you were born.
I can't think of anything more nature than that,
but there's a nurture component too.
You didn't all hear the same songs as a teenager.
Some of you were 18 in 1971 when stairway to heaven was hitting the airwaves.
Some of you were 18 in 1991 when Alannis Morissette was entering the the
airwaves and some of you were 18 and 2012 when Taylor swift was busy making her
mark.
Even within a single country like this,
the cultures are different so we have nature when you were born and nurture the
cultural impact on your life and all of a sudden we have the book there.
It is in a nutshell,
nature and nurture and aging.
Now there were two origins about this book.
My task was to write a book about aging brains and still keep nature and nurture
in sight.
There was both a relational origin and a quantitative origin.
The relational,
I think you'd be described by talking about Tom Hanks that informed the audience
I wished to try to address as I was writing the book,
but the quantitative origins were percentages,
the relative contributions of nature and nurture to the whole process of aging,
which is actually something you can measure.
So we're going to do Tom Hanks first and they'll do the quantitative and then
we'll do the law,
the first chapter,
the last chapter,
and then we'll be done.
Okay,
so Tom Hanks,
Tom Hanks and I are the same age and so as you might expect,
I would be writing for Tom Hanks in his night.
I'm 61 years old.
Tom Hanks in his late fifties early sixties incarnation for sure.
And part of the audience is for this because we're asking questions about what
you can do given that your brain,
the cognitive components of uh,
of brain processing is changing and so on.
So that would be make some sense.
What might not be too obvious though was the fact that I also this book for 24
year olds and 30 year olds and there's a very specific reason why I bracketed
that age group.
It's a younger audience.
This is because of the evolutionary considerations of our past history,
which was inspired by a quote from Thomas Hobbs.
How many of you remember Thomas Hobbes?
Great Caveman quote,
cave person quote,
the natural state of men was solitary,
poor,
nasty,
brutish and short for hundreds of thousands ne millions of years,
depending upon where you put homo erectus these days,
most of us died before our 30th birthday.
We didn't have a 40th birthday,
we didn't have a 50th birthday.
There was no such thing as grandparents for millions of years,
hundreds of thousands of years.
It was all over by 30 and Darwin agrees with Thomas.
Hobbs shows up lots of different ways.
Most of the metabolic processes that that make you functional have piqued by age
30 and then there's a slow decline after that.
Many of us think that selective pressure on our bunnies peaking at 30 that's
enough to give your kids and then have your kids give kids and then you become
irrelevant.
And if you're going to live longer than that,
it's going to be genetic freefall.
So if we agree with Tom Hobbs at the hard world of Darwin,
is there an average age?
Selective pressure on fitness is only going to occur for us to about here before
the Upper Paleolithic early humans really did die young most for their 30th
birthday.
That's a an anthropologist out of Michigan,
but you have many,
many metabolic processes which start their failures here.
The brain peaks even earlier.
I'm going to show that in just a second,
but that simply means there's genetic freefall past the age of 24 to 30 if I'm
going to write a book about human aging,
I'm not going to be addressing 65 year olds and expect to capture all of our
evolutionary history.
I need to write to 30 year olds because after 30 you're already aging,
you're already declining and your brain's peaked.
We're going to show this by series of Wexler.
A approximations peaked at age 24 so congratulations.
For most of you in this room,
it's all over,
mostly by age 24 if you take a look at the standard Wexler scores,
and this is,
and it took actually quite a while ago,
here's the reference for it.
What we're going to do is we're going to take a look at what you'll see is that
peak cognitive talents,
uh,
it's kind of asynchronous.
There are some that peak early,
there are some of the peak lake,
but the vast majority of them peak your brain peaks at very specific,
uh,
windows depending on how you've a few about feel about a Wexxar psychometric
assays.
Here's the year that peak is achieved from zero to 60.
Uh,
and the type of cognitive abilities,
a short term memory word pairs at peaked at 13.
Okay.
Similarity profiles,
which is a form of pattern matching peaks at age 40.
Your vocabulary peaks at age 50 and say goodbye to everything else because
everything else was in the middle.
Digital symbol and encoding,
long term visual,
visual processing,
picture block design,
object assembly,
digital spans a backwards,
a spatial longterm memory faces reverse list and about a thousand more that I
can put average them.
It's 23.96.
That's when you peak and everything else declines in the median is actually
quite close to this.
So even though it's a synchronous,
there really is a cluster right around there.
So it's a research question.
If I were to write an audience write for an audience of 65 year olds,
but I really could be writing for an audience of 24 year olds,
is there such a thing as a cognitive four o one k for the mind?
Should you be starting to do some things now when you are earlier investing now
that will pay dividends later when you do get to 65 and you actually can feel
the effects of accumulative longterm erosion that actually began at 24 25 I will
call that mostly a research idea because the real question is we don't know.
But another way of thinking about aging would be to think of it not at,
not in terms of Aa RP land,
but in terms of when you're just busy,
uh,
getting rid of your student loans.
So most metabolic processes fail here.
Your cognitive decline fails.
They're investing in age friendly behaviors here.
Does that make sense?
And think of the idea as a cognitive 401k for these ages such that by the time
your post 30 there's some things you really want to be doing.
If you really want to keep your mind fresh and lively up to what we think is the
genetic maximum of anywhere between hundred and 15 in the hundred and 22 years.
That means my audience for this book wasn't just Tom Hanks in his sixties it's
also Tom Hanks in his twenties and thirties so that's my audience.
Okay.
Second origin,
I told you there was a quantitative origin.
This is a quantitative relationship between nature and nurture.
To understand some numbers though,
I have to define a few terms for you when we talk about,
you've heard the term longevity and then acts as a formal definition in,
in uh,
in my world,
a longevity simply means the amount of time you could spend on the planet if the
conditions were perfect.
Okay.
How much time?
It's probably genetic in origin,
mostly genetic.
How much time do you have?
If the conditions are perfect,
you don't break a leg,
you know,
get into a war.
You don't a year,
it's perfect.
Okay.
Between 150 to 922 years is what we think it is.
That's different from the concept of lifespan.
Lifespan is the number of years you can survive on the planet given the
conditions are hardly perfect,
okay?
You might be in a war,
you might be in the Serengeti and then gargle or Craner for a million years.
Uh,
the lifespan for most of us was around right around age 30,
as I said,
and it really didn't start accelerating much until a turn of the last century in
the United States where you could actually increase your lifespan to between 39
and 40 years of age.
Now it's double that.
It's almost 80 years of age,
but heading towards the idea of how can you make your lifespan equal,
your longevity and how can you transit through that and keep your brain healthy.
Inhale being as how you live to 115 to 122 if you did certain things.
Well that's actually been quantitative as quantitatively assessed.
Here's what is a quote from the book all told anywhere between 25 and 33% of the
variants in life expectancy,
there's your life expectancy can be explained by how well you chose your
parents,
so there's a strong genetic component to how long you're going to live,
but only strong in the,
in the sense of you think that between 25 and 33% is strong because the rest of
it is not nature at all.
The rest of it's that guy.
The rest of it's nurture,
so this much is going to be up to your helix.
This much is going to be up to your lifestyle.
What do we know about this that could transform a lifespan which really isn't
geared for much selective pressure much be on 24 to 30 and make it last an
additional 70 years being as how that's what most of your life is going to be.
Well,
there's the book,
we know 10 things.
There are 10 things well subscribed and anchored in the peer reviewed literature
that can change this number to the affirmative and increase your lifespan so
that life span and longevity begin to approach something of parody.
I'm not going to go through all of them,
I can't,
but the rest of the book is about that.
There are 10 of them.
Relationships,
gratitude,
mindfulness,
learning video games.
Yet by just said video games,
Alzheimer's diet,
sleep,
lifespan and retirement.
We're going to go through relationships that we're going to go through and
finally get into retirement,
so if you're taking notes,
I advise you not to because as you can see,
I speak nearly at the speed of light,
but that's okay because I'll tell you where I am at any one part of the lecture.
We're going to talk about the first chapter Sunday.
That's going to sound really squishy at first,
but actually isn't very squishy at all and have something very powerful to say
to people that are still in the process of navigating their social
relationships.
Here is the first rule.
We've got 10 of them to go by.
We're going to get to that guy,
be a friend to others and that others be a friend to you.
I'm going to start with a negative illustration of this principle.
If I say the word,
what am I going to show my age?
How many of you remember dear Abby,
does anybody remembered your heavy from way back when and about half of you?
Okay.
For those of you who did not raise your hand,
dear Abby was though an advice columnist from way back when.
Uh,
and uh,
she had a monozygotic,
twin Derren and lamb and lenders who also was an advice columnist and they hated
each other's guts for most of their lives.
Yet they both wrote and Abby wrote a book about some of her favorite letters of
all time.
Here I've got a great illustration of the friends you do not want to be.
This is not something that's going to get you to your 115 year maximum.
Dear Abby,
I'm an Italian men age 34.
I am of medium build and I'm told that I am good looking.
I drive a sightseeing bus by day.
So I speak a little English.
I am single and would like to correspond with an American woman between the ages
of 30 and 65.
She doesn't have to be beautiful,
but I want one who has a steady income and owns a late model.
American automobile.
If you know of a woman who like to correspond with me,
please ask her to send a picture of the automobile job.
Not particularly socially competent,
more to the experience of the elderly.
This is a,
an anecdote I actually have in the book.
It's on the subject of loneliness will,
when we start out with a relational chapter,
a journalist was interviewing a woman is a quote from the book.
A journalist was interviewing a woman named Molly Holderness on her hundred and
third birthday.
Tell us Mrs Holderness,
what do you think is the best thing about being 103?
The journalist asked Mrs Holderness look,
the journalists straight in the eye,
her response was quick and good humored.
No peer pressure.
She said simply,
the reason why I leave with that anecdote is something that actually was a
little heartbreaking and going through is I,
uh,
I've known certainly about the molecules and have been invested in,
in my career for almost 35,
40 years now.
Uh,
but what I went through when I was writing this book,
I went to go visit a system learning living,
uh,
facilities,
what used to be called nursing homes and whatnot.
And I would ask people about how they felt about growing old [inaudible] 75.
There are 80,
85 years old and almost universally,
and maybe it was just as hardly as it was,
not a randomized,
blinded anything.
They used one word and they set it all the time.
They felt like increasingly they were invisible
people stop touching him.
Okay.
When they talked to them,
they would talk to them like children and they would raise the amplitude of
their voices if they could not there,
except if they were invisible
in the literature.
About 40% of American seniors feel that way.
And we are only in the beginning stages of understanding how toxic those
feelings are to the brain.
It hurts somatic tissue and it hurts neural cells.
Lowliness can even increase the probability of death.
And if you're in the throes of it where you're starting to get what we call f
three three.one depressions or anxiety disorders,
you've got some issues.
There are some physiological effects of loneliness that are worth going through.
Any roads,
cognitive function,
increased memory dysfunction,
and perceptual speed decreases is what you can measure.
The laboratory erodes immune function.
If you feel lonely,
increased risk for viral infections and we have a greater risk for cancer,
uh,
it will also elevate your stress hormone levels.
You have an increased risk for hypertension,
increased risk for stroke,
increased risk for heart disease.
And here's the biggie.
Probability of death is 45%.
If you feel invisible then for seniors that are socially active,
why those loneliness do that to seniors?
We actually think we know why.
And there are two concepts you would need to understand in order to,
I mean,
still in camera range there.
The,
uh,
um,
in order for us to understand it,
one of them is that you need to know that your body can undergo systemic
inflammation,
low level inflammation.
It's just like the information you get when you get cut,
but you can get it throughout your body and your body does not like it.
And I'll show you how much it doesn't like it because the brain doesn't like it.
Um,
you probably know neurons,
about 10% of the brain is filled with neurons.
And in order for a neuron to work well,
it needs to be insulated.
Okay?
Just like the plastic on a copper wire needs to be insulated.
If a neuron is insulated,
it's insulated with something we call white matter.
So it looks white under,
under the observing conditions that we make.
If a neuron is insulated with white matter,
it can click along.
A signal can be propagated about a hundred meters per second,
but if you remove the Myelin sheaving,
that's what that white matter is called.
If you remove the Myelin,
now the signal can only propagate it about one meter per second and it's usually
scattered in diffuse.
You do not want your installation gone,
but that's exactly what systemic inflammation does.
It attacks white matter in the brain
hobbles cognitive function simply because you feel invisible.
It looks like this.
In fact,
we can think of it as kind of a four stage process of it because it actually
repeats itself because when you feel chronically lonely,
an invisible,
does that make you more gregarious or less?
What do you think?
Do you think that makes you want to go,
oh,
well it's so good to see you and then no one sees you.
And so you call out step one chronic loneliness is experience.
Yep,
I'm chronically lonely.
This is such a big deal that the systemic inflammation that's going to occur is
this gets you the same numbers as if you were smoking two packs a day regularly,
or if you were morbidly obese.
So loneliness,
induce systemic inflammation is as at comparable levels to people who smoke or
are morbidly obese.
Step three,
inflammation damages,
white matter into the brain,
that's for sure what it does.
And that leads to increased withdrawing behavior and the cycle just repeats
itself.
So it's not a small thing to say that having friends and being able to be
socially competent,
it's an extraordinarily vital,
I would say precarious thing for an elderly brain.
And if elderly brains feel shut in in your and your mom and your dad feels like
nobody is visiting them and they get systemic inflammation,
you can hobble their ability to think,
okay.
And if you socialize them,
I'll show you how we measure socialization.
You can reverse all that bad stuff I just said.
Hence the rule,
socialization and brain function.
Okay.
How will we measure socialization?
We measured these what are called social integration scores.
Uh,
and the measurements actually simple and straight forward.
What you'll do is you'll look at marital status,
we look at volunteer activities,
frequency of contact with family,
frequency of contact with neighbors.
And then we assign you a poorly integrated or a highly integrated score.
And you're somewhere around there.
So when we take a look at people that are socially integrated versus not,
and we're looking at their brain function,
here's what we find chiefly.
There is both a positive and a negative component to this,
but the higher your social integration score here,
the better your brain resists.
The cognitive effects of aging and buffers against the effects of loneliness.
Okay.
The more friends you have,
the more you can buffer against all that bad stuff or the more highly integrated
you are.
Like I said,
there's both a negative and a positive to this.
Memory decline occurs at twice the rate for seniors that score here than
seniors.
That score here measured over a 12 year period.
Socially isolated seniors,
global memory scores.
A memory is a,
is a multifaceted gadgets.
We have to kind of think of gross domestic product,
but you can get at it.
A global memory score falls at twice the rate,
so socializing effects of memory.
One of the things you can do is that for people that are becoming increasingly
isolated socially,
they begin to forget things at about twice the rate of an interactive senior,
so that's the negative part.
There's a positive component to this too.
Global cognitive decline,
which is a measure of processing speed and executive function in a whole range
of really good things.
Global cognitive decline,
which occurs naturally when you age is 70% less,
77 0% less if you score in the highly integrated range than if you score in the
poorly integrated range.
So,
uh,
if that's the,
if that's the negative effects,
the positive effects are going to be something like this.
A high socialization score versus a low socialization score,
a 70% reduction in the rate of general global cognitive decline compared to low.
We even have some neuro anatomy.
We can work with this.
We now know what it does.
Once you stop the de Myelination of the brain,
we'll get it nice and insulated.
You also actually promote growth if you are regularly interacting with people.
So here's a quote from the journal Nature.
As Chelsea Waltz,
a quote,
researchers suspect that the cognitively demanding act of socializing can
actually build up the brain,
like exercising builds up muscle.
This brain reserve may then act as a buffer against functional loss,
even in the face of conditions as Alzheimer's disease.
Here's what we think is going on with the brain in particular,
the frontal lobe,
particularly the prefrontal lobe,
you see gray matter volume increases.
The more socialized you have somebody that's involved in decision making,
attentional states executive function,
which is a measure of impulse control and cognitive control.
People have good executive functioning often really terrific at math.
Okay,
so the ability to understand that the loneliness can actually change in math
score is probably where that data goes and I'm not making that up.
Amygdala volume doubles involved in emotion generation and emotional memory.
So your ability actually to feel things except at something besides being
invisible.
Can is something that's available.
And then something in the enter Renal Cortex,
the underwriter,
the cortex is how many of you've heard of the hippocampus before?
Have you heard of that before?
Okay.
You can think of the NRL cortex is kind of a gateway into the hippocampus
because it's involved in memory and that gray matter volume also increases.
The more you socialize.
It's involved in memory formation and storage.
And so I have a piece of advice for you.
The first of two in this lecture.
Number one,
become socially competent
at age 24 because the erosion has already started at 25 cultivate friendships,
learn how to become a friend,
then have lots of them and sustain them over a long period of time.
Number two,
cultivate family ties.
It's actually a much more predictive of social interactions,
mostly because you're stuck with your family.
So if you have problems with your family,
one of the best things you can start doing it.
Start repairing your relationships now because it's already declining and you're
going to depend on them later.
And finally,
if you've got elderly loved ones,
do the same thing for them as recommendations.
Number one,
become a friend and recommendation.
Number two,
repair your family life.
So I have some pieces of advice that's probably anchored fairly well in the Peer
Review Literature after age 24 learn to cultivate and maintain an active base of
friends.
Interact with them often.
24 is not too early to start.
Neither is 65 recommendation number two,
actively cultivate,
maintain and repair familial relationships.
24 is not too early to start,
neither is 65.
And then finally,
recommendation number three for your elderly loved ones.
Make sure they follow recommendation number one.
Then recommendation number two,
not for any other reason.
If you well,
then self survival.
But the more you do that for others,
the more you will help yourself.
Let's go the last part of the book,
the last chapter,
the power of reminiscing.
And then if we have some time,
I will go towards the middle.
Uh,
this is unusual.
I think there's a lot of people are not familiar with Ellen.
Langer is great work,
but here's the brain will,
I'm going to focus on the last sentence of this brain rule in retirement.
Never retire and be sure to reminisce.
Doesn't mean you can't leave your job.
It just means that you have to keep your brain active for a long,
long time.
So the more you can get an active now and you're engaged in an act,
in a brain active job as your profession,
the better off you're going to be.
If you continue that,
even when you,
uh,
start collecting pensions or whatever,
withdrawing from your 401k looks like to you.
We're going to focus on this.
We're not gonna focus on retirement that we're going to focus on the be sure to
reminisce.
Now,
what I mean by reminiscence actually it can be fairly well defined,
but I'll give the subjective example.
Does anybody know who that is?
Some of you are probably familiar.
If you've ever gone to a grocery store and been buy baby food products.
You already know who this is.
She's Anna Turner Cook.
This is her
when she was six months old.
This is an Turner Cook.
He's the original Gerber baby at age seven and 87 and I heard some awes in there
that is a dopamine lollipop and you are beginning to react to the idea of
reminiscing.
Okay?
For those of you who raised your hands when you knew the lyrics to stairway to
heaven,
folks who's that
look familiar to them.
This could be a whole bunch of people here that are just not going to get this,
but about half of you will,
you have seen these people before.
If you've,
you've seen these people before.
If you were eight years old back in the 60s because this is the gang from Eddie
Haskell,
beaver and Wally from an old television show called leave it to beaver only.
This is now,
they were all eight and 10 and,
and six years old back then and now they're not.
So if you have any pattern matching here at all and you have a reminiscence bump
at it and you reacted to those or react to whatever the leave it to beavers are
in your life,
we actually can measure that reaction.
And we have found some extraordinary things and I want to tell you about Ellen
Langer is work to talk about it.
We begin with a puzzling headline.
Uh,
what's interesting about this is for the New York Times,
this was published this year and in it in May reliving communist past helps east
German dementia patients.
Okay.
Most of you probably did not read this scintillating article.
What is the world does that mean?
And what is there any brain science underneath that?
Dementia is certainly going to be reactive to that.
Well,
there is,
there is an ability to explain this and I'm gonna show you the person who can
explain it the best.
Her name is Ellen Langer.
She is the first woman to be tenured at psychology at Harvard.
She's still there and she's very famous for doing something called the counter
clockwise experiment.
It's a very famous experiment in my world and I want to talk to you about the
counterclockwise experiment a little bit,
but it won't make much sense unless we first talk about some background
information that let Helen to design the experiment the way she did.
She looked at the effects of the style dish.
He looked at that dopamine lollipop you gave yourselves when you saw the Gerber
baby,
if you did,
and she also looked at something that we call retrieval bias.
So the ability to look at a power reminisces and retrieval bias gives us our
counterclockwise experiments.
So let's do,
let's unpack each of those first nostalgia and then the a retrieval bias.
I'm going to say something surprising.
I use the word weird and the title of this talk nostalgia is good for you.
We used to not think that.
And if you have a take the American value of let's push the forward,
let's put them all forward.
Let's,
let's do some new things.
And I've been in research land virtually,
uh,
like I say three or four decades now.
I'm used to loving the new and hating the old,
that's for sure.
We used to think that dwelling on the past was universally bad.
Uh,
the turns out that that's not right,
that a regular dose of healthy nostalgia actually does extraordinary things for
the brain.
And I want to show it to you.
First of all,
it's a psychometric evidence.
When people reminisce,
three things happen that you can measure first their social connected to scores
go up.
It's that stuff we were talking about.
We are looking at highly integrated versus low integrated.
Number two eudemonic wellbeing scores go up.
This is a sense of,
uh,
the closest I can give it to you is the idea of fulfillment.
So if you love what you do here at Google,
you are fulfilled by your job.
If you love what you do outside in somewhere else,
usually it measured by the absence of depression,
absence of anxiety disorders,
but we'll be,
your feeling of wellbeing goes up with a more reminiscence and you have a
greater frequency of positive memories.
The more you reminisce,
the more positive memories you start percolating up into your brain and the more
positive you become.
No kidding.
So the idea that nostalgic could actually be forward thinking can actually do
something to an exposure to an astounding experience.
There's an objective psychometric assessment.
There's also a subjective one.
Social connectedness scores go up,
you demonic wellbeing increases.
That's that sense of fulfillment and greater frequency of positive memories.
You're looking on the study side.
You have an optimum bias,
optimism bias towards,
uh,
recalled experience.
That's terrific.
We also now know that most of the people that regularly dig into their nostalgia
that regularly dig into the things that were the leave it to beaver,
the Gerber baby,
whatever that is to your world,
certain perspectives change that you can also measure.
Number one,
your death related anxiety decreases.
Okay?
The more nostalgic you become,
the less you are afraid of death.
Number two,
feelings of intimacy.
Increase with the people that are around you,
your friends,
your family,
and your friends,
feelings of feeling close to them do.
And number three,
this is the most extraordinary of all your greater tolerance.
You have a greater tolerance for outsiders.
You get a greater tolerance for outsiders.
The more you reflect on your own experience,
especially with when there are perceived social differences,
which is the fracture that usually hits most of this country.
So subjective behavioral assessments are strong.
Death related anxiety decreases intimacy,
increases feeling emotionally close to loved ones,
and a greater tolerance of outsiders,
especially ones with perceived social differences.
So it's a big old thing to say that there is a power of nostalgia.
It's one that,
uh,
Ellen Langer could take in spades when she's designing her counterclockwise
experiment.
We also know that there are a neurophysiological changes that you can measure.
The more you have a,
um,
uh,
a nostalgic experiences and more irregularly traffic in nostalgia.
And the reason why that we know about this,
every time you have an astrologer experience,
your brain gives you a little bit of dopamine and this is really good when
you're 65 because you're,
your dopamine levels are naturally decreasing.
That naturally happens.
Gonna happen to everybody in this room unless you keep that kite blowing up,
unless you keep it upward,
dopamine levels are going to continue to go down.
You want as much dopamine as you can get.
Don't.
Amit is your reward center.
When you feel good about something,
you're getting dopamine.
When dopamine is also involved in motor control,
kill off the substantia Nigra and other areas that are involved in a dope m
energic responses and you'll get a Parkinson's disease.
Parkinson's disease is the absence of a dope dope,
I mean smart,
so it's involved in motor a motor control.
It's also involved in learning when you feel like you're learning better,
so what you want is as much dopamine as you can get.
What happens when you become the static is it's your buddy gets warmer and the
dope m energy system is stimulated in two specific areas.
This is a mid sagittal section through the brand.
You cut it like it's a Bagel and we're going to see in green here it's only
about eighty thousand ninety thousand neurons of the dope energic system was
actually a pretty small,
but we're going to focus on two specific areas right here that whenever you get
under style,
just spike these things light as if it were the 4th of July,
so you get an exposure to an established,
you experience the nucleus accumbens and the ventral tegmental areas light up as
if it were the 4th of July,
and the more nostalgia you get,
the more dopamine you pump into the system.
Okay,
so ms style,
Joe was the first great peer that Ellen Langer was using to design her counter
clockwise.
Now to the next one,
retrieval bias was the other great peer that she utilized in creating the con.
The counterclockwise experiment put simply retrievable bias is that memory
retrieval across your lifespan is uneven.
We call one a reminiscence bump.
You retrieve events that occurred at some ages better than others.
Do you know what your best age at retrieval is?
Ages 24 to 30 if you're 80 years old and I measured the number of memories that
you both get right and even the sequence of it,
right?
You Spike at that magic age at the place where the system appears to have been
optimized,
it's less than your thirties and forties.
You need a little spike what's coming up.
Um,
most of you will age out of culture before you age out of brain,
but give you an idea of how that can actually work with,
I'll show you the graph in a second.
How many of you remember that phone numbers
use to have alphabets associate?
In fact,
they were the Alpha numeric proposition for a long time.
You remember that?
You might remember the census.
We're keeping music as our theme here.
There were some phone numbers that were given as pop songs that were actually
the name of the pop sockets self and showing that you can age out of culture
before you age out of Britain.
You might still remember these.
Anybody remember this?
Pennsylvania six,
5,000 some of you are already humming it along like three of you.
That was something.
Glenn Miller Orchestra.
The 1940s how about this one?
Beachwood four five seven,
eight nine.
Does anybody remember beach with four five,
seven,
eight,
nine.
There is one person who has raised their hand besides me and here.
Okay.
That's the Marvelettes in 1962 but here is an ear worm that I'll bet some of you
have because her name is Jenny.
What phone number am I describing it?
I just heard it at six dammit.
Five three Oh nine you met Tommy to tone.
You have a bias for retrieval at a specific age.
The reminiscence bump on average,
it's been measured with six different inputs.
I'll show you.
One of them will do the music one,
but the reminiscence effect after age 80 this has been measured with 80 year
olds.
So what you're going to see here is this.
This is the percentage of memories that you recall that are both accurate in
terms of the content as well as the sequence.
So there's both an ordinal and a,
a a content component of this chronic,
illogical age at time of encoding.
It looks like that you pink right around here.
Look at that.
24 25 and it's bigger as your,
there's your cognitive decline that's speeding to occur.
So you can figure it as three.
The first hill is the reminiscence bump.
That's what we call it.
The middle aged valley is right here.
And then finally the Second Hill,
which are the recency effect.
You can see they're five categories of memory,
have been tested six altogether.
And I'll show you one books,
political events,
films,
autobiographical events,
music.
In fact,
they were originally counts before it got a little more rigorous.
They would couch it with things like when re tell the name of a book that meant
the most to you.
Now tell me when you read it,
tell me a film you saw that meant the most to you.
Tell me when you saw it.
Tell me the music that meant the most to you and tell me when you heard it and
so on and so forth.
So you'll see these things,
books,
political events,
films,
autobiographical memories and music.
Let's do just do the music cause we're staying with that theme.
When did you encounter the best popular music you ever listened to?
And the answer is right there through the ages of 15 to 25 in fact,
after about 25 or so,
you no longer think music is any good.
You know,
it's all good way back when,
and there's a great quote,
what people regard as the music of my generation.
This is actually from a peer of your literature because it around it and then a
book begins at around the time they're 14 or 15 then ends in their late twenties
a graph of the preferences can be summarized very simply.
Pop Music was at its best when I was around 20 and went and went downhill
rapidly from then on.
Okay?
That is retrieval by us and retrieval bias was selling because not only do you
remember it better,
you apparently also prefer it better,
which tells me there's going to be a dopamine tag of some kind.
So what's going to happen is that right around the age when you are at your
cognitive maximum,
the best books you've ever read,
the best music you've ever heard,
the best political speeches,
we didn't talk about political,
a ideologies and inputs to it,
but the best films that you ever saw and certainly your life events.
And here's the Biggie here.
Not only do you remember them,
you seem to prefer that.
And with that in mind,
I can talk to you about Ellen Langer's powerful counterclockwise experiment.
Here she is,
and here's a reference.
It's written up the New York Times a couple years ago,
what it is.
She took a bunch of old men in their seventies and eighties some of them were
not very ambulatory and she knew the power of reminiscence and she knew the
power of retrieval bias.
She rented out a monastery,
a little west of Cambridge,
and fitted out the monastery with postdocs and graduate students and turned the
monastery into 1959
closed circuit TV.
President Eisenhower is busy on there.
Yeah,
you want to watch a football game?
It's going to be Johnny Unitas and the Frickin Baltimore Colts and the
Minneapolis Lakers and food.
That was going to be reminiscence of what w what you could see in 1959 they
weren't allowed to bring any pictures except if it was them in their
reminiscence bump in there.
24 hours and 25 and 30 years old.
No mirrors were allowed and the staff,
there were certainly physicians on staff to watch this,
but the staff would not let them act like they were 80 if they have problems
bringing up their suitcase up the stairs because there was no elevator tough.
You open up the suitcase in the lobby and you brought up the the shirt one at a
time because for the next week it's going to be 1959
and what happened was amazing because of course you did the bass lines.
She's just going to get it all the,
all the motor skills and all the cognitive skills and somatic skills of what was
happening and then watch.
And the only thing I can tell you is I'm going to use the word magic occurred or
if you've seen the movie cocoon of the cocoon occurred because things began to
change.
She noticed almost immediately that they were becoming more ambulatory.
There were walking more,
they were laughing more.
They're seem to be more cool things that were occurring to them as in their
interactions per se.
She began to notice something that was really strange there.
Um,
fingers,
we're lengthening,
their fingers were lengthening,
their eyesight was changing,
their hearing was changing.
In fact,
if you measure all these,
the somatic means hearing sensitivity as best at threshold intensities of the
thousand and 6,000 hertz was just better vision near point.
Vision improved,
especially in the right I oddly enough manual dexterity because they were now
moving more.
It seemed like we were interacting,
at least they were back in 1959 so their bodies thought they were back in 1959
we're beginning to stretch.
Whole body dexterity improved too.
In fact,
one subject threw away his cane at the very end she gives another cognitive
testifies if there's a 37% increase in what's called the digital civil asset,
which is a powerful cognitive gadget that can actually measure both memory and
processing speed.
You guys,
they changed because she took the reminiscence at the reminiscence bump.
So pre post measures after a monastery experience hearing sensitivity improves
near point vision improves manual dexterity,
improves whole body dexterity scores improved one subject throughway his cane
and in the New York Times this was mentioned.
Oh yeah,
the cod cognition and memory and processing speed improved as measured by the
digital symbol assay.
Um,
Bruce Grierson eventually wrote about this in the New York Times article and
here's what he said though,
she and her students would write up the experiment.
They left out a lot of the tantalizing color,
like the spontaneous touch football game that erupted between here to fort
creaky seniors as they waited for the bus back to Cambridge
just by flooding their heads with dopamine on a sustained level with a continual
spike towards a retrieval bias.
You've got to change in brain.
You got to change in body and now this New York Times headline can make more
sense because what they did was a repetition of the counterclockwise experiment.
Professionals created an east German living area according environments and
Dresden for the mid 1960s after the wall fell,
and what they did is it,
the food was and Gary and salad of the 1960s which was sausage and bell peppers
and tomatoes,
the kitchen that the dishes were watching,
the original 1960s East German middle sink,
salt and pepper vent,
vintage plastic east German shakers from an old cal follow supermarket laundry
clothes were washed with old East Germans Bay and follow laundry detergents.
This is going to be smell.
Okay,
so we're going to get an all factory spike that's coming.
Clothes were ironed with mid 20th century pressing ironed,
so you're going to get the feel of what it was,
what it would be to be like if that detergent were soaked into the cloth and
then you iron it out and then finally you've got your magazines and you've got
your music.
You had all kinds of things.
All of a sudden,
I have another piece of advice for you.
I told you there were two.
Here's my second.
The second piece of advice would be this.
It's another set harness.
The power of nostalgia.
Step number one,
this is for your loved ones.
Designate a living area as a nostalgia room for your loved one's brain.
Mom,
dad,
Grandpa,
uncle,
loved beloved mentor.
Step number to calculate your loved ones,
reminiscence,
bump years.
And step number three,
fill the nostalgia room with objects and experiences from the calculated and
spoke years.
Make sure it is multisensory.
The better you can get it,
the more multisensory you can make it,
the better.
And for you in the 24 to 30 30 year old,
I have another piece of advice.
Start collecting objects,
Tokens and experiences from your own reminiscence bump years.
Put them in storage to get ready to make your own freaking room
if you want to change in memory and finger length and executive function and all
the things that come by are routine re [inaudible] of your brain to a dope.
Emma needs a dopamine metabolism.
I am my own reminiscence bump and I'll close with this and want to take some
questions.
Um,
how many read?
Anybody remember this guy?
You know who that is?
Yeah,
I just heard it.
Who is it?
Art Linkletter.
For those of you who don't know who art Linkletter is,
he uh,
was in 1912,
2010.
I remember seeing this heat for those who don't know,
he had a variety show in the early sixties with uh,
uh,
the last 10 minutes.
If I swear you guys,
if it had been done now you,
that would be probably a third most traffic youtube channel.
That would be because he had kids say the darndest thing last 10,
10 segment,
this 10 minute segments he put,
I'll put the kids on the stool and then he would go around and ask them
interesting questions and remember this is live television and I will never
forget this as long as I live because I actually saw this and asked my mom about
it.
Uh,
I can't show it to you cause it doesn't exist,
but there is a,
there is this about it.
Okay.
Remember this is live television.
Uh,
last 10 minute segment art asked a boy his favorite question,
Tami,
what would make you happy?
The boy replied a bed of my own that would make me happy,
aren't asked him,
concerned,
don't chew,
sleep in a bed.
The boy replied.
I usually sleep with my mommy and my daddy,
but when my daddy has gone,
mommy sleeps with Uncle Bob
and I have to sleep on the couch.
And anyway,
he's not really my uncle and go,
I got to cover herself.
It's funny when you look back at life,
I've never been 61 before.
I'm going to be 62 but about two months.
But what are the great joys in writing this book is that there was a tremendous
amount of hope and powerful things that you can do practically at any age.
If you want to be enjoying art Linkletter way into your hundred and 15,
122.
Uh,
it's probably the,
one of the biggest reasons I wrote the book was to show that even if you're 24
or 30,
or 62 or 80,
there's a heck of a lot of things you can do out there.
Thank you very much.
I was actually curious,
um,
rather than having a room,
if one of those people were ironing their shorts with the super old irony,
et Cetera,
um,
just on a daily basis,
just one object rather than,
than a room,
would it still work or does it have to be emerging?
Well,
if you want,
I don't know.
That's a good question to ask.
I don't know how you can titrate that.
Uh,
but you could,
you could put it this way,
that if it is true that this is working because you're continually asking Dopa
mean to being re squirted into the environment.
And when you were aging that dopamine levels are always already going,
always going down.
The more you can,
it's like puffs of air onto a cake.
The more you can keep that tight up into the air,
probably the higher it's gonna fly.
And if you don't regularly sustain it,
the dope and manager system is no friend to you.
It's actually going down still.
So it's like you have to keep it up,
which is why I asked it to be perhaps a room that you can regularly visit.
And because you're smart,
you're going to get bored.
So swap it out and change things and what not,
but keep it there.
So the dopamine spike can be regular and sustained it.
Yes,
sir.
Hi,
great talk.
Um,
just one comment and then one question about the reminiscence bump.
Uh,
the comment is there's a great movie called Goodbye Lennon from West Germany
about a family trying to basically do that East German experiment with their
mother.
Um,
check it out.
But then the question is,
especially you said at the start that people tend,
I used to dye a lot earlier.
Yes.
So from an evolutionary genetic point of view,
what is the genetic advantage of the reminiscence bump?
If you're going to be dead by the time you're 30 anyway.
All right.
Do you think the Webinar was Bob started factual?
All it's showing is that the system is really aligned and pumping at ages 24 to
30,
but that there's no distinct advantage to having it at all.
It's just that that is a,
I would think of it as a shadow,
as an echo of something we used to have because after 30 gets genetic free fall,
there's no selective pressure or better to say it's now random.
And for those of you who have really good cardiovascular grandparents,
now we'll also have cardiovascular,
a good cardiovascular health for you.
Oh,
that's just totally genetic and random.
Thank you.
I had a question regarding the 24 year old peak that you mentioned.
A couple of,
uh,
two,
two parts of the question.
One,
the first part is,
um,
when is the derivative,
the maximum.
Um,
so do you have a flat plateau for a while,
uh,
and then really start to fall off.
And then the second part of that question is for let's say a certain category of
folks,
maybe the hobby capable sort of according to the kids' definition.
Is there a different peak potentially?
Is Qp for them?
Yes,
that's very good question.
Uh,
the flat is probably around 25,
26 years of age.
The peak
for highly capable kids.
That is a tough one because it was not segregated for this work that I'm aware.
But I do know that there is an extraordinary piece of data that might hit edit
eventually,
but we'd have to go to an Alzheimer's.
Let's do it.
The,
uh,
um,
if the more highly educated you are,
the less likely you are to get Alzheimer's.
But when you do get Alzheimer's,
the higher educated you are,
the faster your collapses,
you'll go.
Like in two years,
three years as opposed to the normal 7.8 with dribbles out.
So that's about as close to,
it's tangential.
That's about as close as I can get.
But a great question.
Yeah.
So I guess this is a followup question to the all counterclockwise experiment
people were put back into their old beard.
Has there been any follow up experiments on people of like religious orders
where they maintain the same environment for many,
many years of their life and how they affect aging compared to other more?
Number one was more normal members of society.
There is,
it's nothing that would make it into a peer review that I would respectively
because you can't randomize the population.
So they're all going to be in one spot and they all have maybe have a particular
view towards their experience.
You can't say this though because they're kept well track of,
are you guys familiar with the Wisconsin or Minnesota Alzheimer's?
None experiment.
Do you know about this?
And if you heard this before,
this is will.
Again,
it's tangential because the answer is we don't know the uh,
but here it is.
What they have found,
and this is really gives a confounder to Alzheimer's.
A group whole convent in Minnesota decided to donate their brains to science
because they're dying off.
There's going to be anyone else coming in.
And as soon as they were all dying off would donate their brains to science,
to the University of Minnesota where they would do brain slices,
pop up in the cranial vault and take a look and see because they were interested
in Alzheimer's.
And even in that close community where it is not randomized,
that's for sure.
And that's a,
that's a confounder here.
Um,
Alzheimer's disease,
there was a woman named Marie Marie was 94 years old when she died and she was
teaching as a teaching order,
so it'd been addictive.
So she was teaching it all the time.
It had lots of students and whatnot.
When you cracked open her brain,
when she was dead and look at it,
it looked like someone had taken a 12 gauge shotgun and blew it away.
It was finished.
It had lots of those amyloid plaques familiar with amyloid plaques,
neurofibrillary deposits,
things that are all Alzheimer's like get,
she showed no signs of Alzheimer's at all.
There is another woman,
other women who had died who had what I call screaming at the walls,
Alzheimer's in the tertiary,
uh,
portions of this and they are truly catastrophic,
really sick and I have a full on dementia and the memory,
it's a normal 7.8 years.
When you open up their brains,
it looks like your brain or my brain without Alzheimer's wasn't fenestrated.
There were no fibrillary ta,
tangles,
there was no whatever.
So the only the closed in populations for things like a religious order you can
get some data from,
but that's as close as it gets.
Otherwise.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Regarding the social relationships to terms social media pets,
I do know pets for certain amounts of loneliness,
that's for sure.
Pets are very powerful and can work really,
really well and people transfer all kinds of things to them and so,
or there's even a pet therapy that can be utilized to a gate.
It's not as good as a human interaction because even though pets are adaptive
and there's lots of cool things you can do,
you can get more interactions with petsmart.
Social media has been tested and by God if it doesn't work,
it's not as good as a full flush on blood.
You're not going to get the pressure differential that you know,
the brain is so good at to get even detect a micro changes in air pressure and
all that other stuff.
But it has been tested and it will actually rescue certain types of loneliness.
So if they're shut in and there's nothing else that can be done,
by Golly,
social media is a friend and it has been tested.
Great question.
Yes sir.
My mom was a extremely passionate about her work her entire career.
She is about to retire but doesn't have any hobbies.
Is there anything,
uh,
that you didn't get a chance to put in the book in regards to retirement?
Uh,
two things to look out for.
Well,
let's see if we can address that one specifically because if she doesn't have
any hobbies,
then she has to do a full on search for the next six months to get one.
Okay.
In fact,
it gets several,
but I will,
I will counsel this if I don't know them at all.
But statistically,
this will be the work of Marty Seligman.
One of the best things you can do when you retire is to get out of yourself
enough to begin volunteering on a regular basis.
The more you volunteer making that part of that a hobby,
you know,
when you read,
if you read through that book,
you'll,
you'll notice a constant theme.
And the constant theme is continually getting out of yourself for the benefit of
your brand.
The more you can exercise your brain,
the better it is.
In fact,
one of the best things that can be done that she can start doing now,
and you can too.
This is from Marty Seligman's,
uh,
great work.
It's,
they're called letters of gratitude.
Here's what you do.
You'll find somebody that was a mentor to you that meant a great deal to you and
for your mom.
Just draw a list of all the people that meant something to,
and you know what you're gonna do.
You're gonna write them a 300 word letter.
That's what you're gonna do.
And then if they're in town or even in the area,
you're going to take that letter and you're going to sit there and read it to
them
and try not to cry.
What you will find and what Marty found was that the more you got out of
yourself and your own experiences and started going back into it,
here's the nostalgia bump.
Am I talking about nostalgia?
But here,
startup,
you better.
I am.
When you start getting out of yourself and into other people,
you begin to change rates of anxiety and depressive disorders.
And since at great risk you are when you retire for anxiety and depressive
disorders and you get that up and running.
One of the first things you can do would be what I would call the alternate name
for this book.
You don't have the alternate name.
For my book should be quit being so self centered.
Do we know
what effect,
if any,
there is on the nostalgia bump and and how bumpy it is now that in say the past
15 years,
we have so many more recordings,
pictures,
videos,
Facebook telling you,
here's the thing you posted five years ago.
Do you want to post it again?
That sort of stuff.
Yeah,
good question.
Don't know.
Absolutely.
It's possible that that could get fussed or it's possible that you will begin
reinserting more fake memories because you have more access points to begin
because you,
with retrieval bias,
there's also optimism bias as we discussed and you begin remembering more of the
good stuff and so they're more access points to that.
Other than that,
we're not sure.